guys the world championships have been
so much fun throughout history we've had
these great champions and I really liked
Steines his contribution to chess you
know when I read about Steinitz and I
was a ninth of 13 children grew up in
poverty to actually become the world
champion is something pretty spectacular
the first official world champion right
yeah right and that's really bugs me a
lot because I grew up with Paul Morphy
let me be clear
I thought the guy's games were brilliant
in the 1850 there's no question this guy
was dominant player oh no question
1860 Steinitz yeah Anderson those guys
are really doing it world championship
why isn't there an official world
championship we have to wait till 1886
month well they hadn't arranged it yet
they hadn't set it up there was no
organization in fact that was the age of
the private world championships inside
the fact was that Steines had dominated
everybody he'd won something like 27 out
of 29 matches beating Anderson and
Blackburn and Byrd he's like I showed
I'm the man so he says I'm the world
champion but then super torch shows up
well then he got 70 he got into writing
into math and so he kind of slipped a
little bit people began questioning his
dominance well he wasn't playing so much
cuz he was busy writing over there
tsukitachi shows up and he starts
playing and he starts dominating and
suddenly both of them are saying well
I'm the best so finally in 1886 they
come to an agreement I mean that's
what's happening if you look at these
like negotiations and like how
everything was up for debate because it
was a first world championship from the
time control to the prize fund to the
rules and of course what fascinates me
as the rules are so different than they
are now in that there were so many
decisive games back in those days that
you could say the first to win eight
games it was not a problem or a ten game
or the fact the fact is those matches
for example that one the first one
sign-in Zoo Couture they finally comes
to an agreement he finally saw were
gonna do it they played in the US which
was awesome they started in New York and
of course my home town so awesome still
they come to st. Louis but but they
start with victories - hits him in the
first and in Zook retort many more games
in a row right and it's like what you
don't see that these days for games that
are all losing and you still don't win
them a signage turned it around here and
st. Louis right that's exactly and then
it finishes up in New Orleans so now we
got stats he's the world champion and
then how do you challenge the guy well
this is so that you've got to you got to
put up bids and raise the money yourself
exactly in the world champion is saying
if you don't come up with this kind of
dough this a month you're not gonna
challenge me and people I'm not gonna
accept the chapel can you imagine these
days if Carlson said nah Fabio unless
you come up with two three mil you can't
challenge yeah but you know before we
before we go on to Alaska I did want to
point out how and how crazy it is that
Steinitz began his championship victory
here in st. Louis and I say that because
in New York he kind of got it squashed
right so in history we think of st.
Louis as the turning Boris magnets
became the champion and actually this
year in the Sinquefield Cup we honored
that occasion by putting a plaque at the
menu and you officiated at the banner
that huge banner yeah you took a lot of
days by the way yeah after they finished
the st. Louis leg before they end up
going to New Orleans it took something
like 12 days and apparently they played
whist they play cards and we same place
while they were waiting he's just
hanging out playing cards hey that
sounds like Carlson in Carolina you're
going too far too fast come on really
big but Steinitz
becomes the first official world
champion but beyond that he becomes like
the first chess scientist he introduces
the idea that really there's something
much more about the game and that you
can take a very scientific approach to
numerous positions especially technical
positions I really give that guy a lot
of credit for two bishops versus bishop
at night endings Steinitz man he showed
how to win those types of endings well
he's visited mark instead of the
father of positional chess heads that
matter of fact it all those principles
that he brought out his little quirk he
very quickly King in the middle of the
board in a lot of positions now in those
in those Kings gambit positions where
his King is on but moved three or four
right
but his defensive skills he showed us a
different level that you had to prepare
your attacks away from the Romantic Age
but then he loses to his ultimate
student a guy who gives him all the
respect in the world in manual eyes
exactly and we have the period of
Emmanuel Lasker one little B longest
world champion ever held the world
championship the longest and he just did
amazing he it was sort of like he rose
to the occasion whenever ever there was
occasion and I'm thinking particularly
about a New Yorker Frank Marshall oh he
killed Marshall but the reason and how
and the why that he killed him goes to
show who Manuel Alaska was and the story
is I don't know of his men but the story
is Marshall loses to eight to one he
needs a one to tarish to Siebert tirage
eight to one and Lasker wants to beat
Marshall worse than terrorists to send a
message to tirage that look I'm still
the guy so he beats him eight zero
yeah that's ugly man let me just
completely dominated him going back to
that match though the one which Stein in
Alaska a sinus and Lasker you had to
realize they started off slugging out
out because trading videos first last
one then Stein is one then last one then
sine x1 then they drew a couple of games
then that game seven that game seven was
the game for history because he was down
two pawns was Alaska in that game and
you know we consider Alaska in many ways
the ultimate defender the ultimate
psychologist and to me the ultimate
hustler yeah because he just worked it
and worked in a hustle Stein it's that
game and that was a big game he won that
game and Stein E's couldn't but your two
points up you're the reigning world
champion two pawns up on a guy and you
can't win the game right and then he
proceeds to lose another four in a row
and okay he did swing back but matches
essentially lost decided in Lasker
becomes a champion
and speaking of defense though in sinus
defense you pass is probably with that
match yeah I was like thirty years older
last was a good twenty five right but it
was a it was definitely the changing of
the guard last one goes right to defeat
him in the rematch and it was a new
agent chess and a long green for
Steinitz as well I mean but the that
really also shows how chess intersects
with history that there's sometimes been
these kind of artificial pauses in a
World Championships because of World War
one and later World War two you know you
didn't get as many matches as you
wouldn't normally exactly well the
machine well certainly it was certainly
a fun time and that's the the old age of
chess the epic age it's always fun to go
back and visit those oral World
Championships for sure